okay marge season 11 this is your
fourth season on the show where does
this line up if you had to rank your
four seasons is this the number one one
i would say it's one of my best seasons
for sure
um you know know what no one physically
attacked me thank the lord
[Music]
but it was emotional i i loved it the
best maybe because i wrote my book i'm
finally renovating my house
it's enjoyable we have solid
relationships i was happy to get the
hell out of the house from the pandemic
so i think it's one of my better seasons
but i loved every single one of them for
different reasons
yeah but this one it is we're finally
seeing the home come together yes
yes and i know you're gonna we're gonna
see part of the
book writing journey this season too yes
yes
which was which was very therapeutic and
emotional
well before we get into all that let's
go to what we've seen so far this season
teresa versus jackie in your living room
i know what was really going through
your head when that was happening
downstairs
awesome saying is why are people saying
this like did you ever hear the saying
when
was there's smoke there's fire
teresa says it's true she's saying where
there's smoke there's fire what are we
gonna say what am i gonna say she's
saying it's true i'm having a freak out
i am gonna tell you this price i really
thought they were going to make up
teresa came in the good mood jackie was
emotional
i said this is going to play on teresa's
emotions she's going to feel guilty and
they're going to make up
when i heard this screaming i was like
holy
crap this is going south i really was
running back and forth because i didn't
know what was
going to happen and i knew jackie was so
emotional and so upset
and taken aback and theresa just it
flipped the switch
and it wasn't an analogy it definitely
was an analogy
not the best one to use i'm just going
to say that
um but it still was one and theresa
just you know it was like the red
you know blanket to the bowl and it went
awry i did not spread a rumor i
heard a rumor okay well you know what i
heard that gia snorts coke in the
bathroom at parties okay
i heard it i don't know where i heard it
from i mean i heard from somebody here
i mean but it's the same thing so how is
that not the same
will we get resolution on this will we
learn where theresa heard this
information from how does this
drama wrap up because i understand it it
doesn't last the whole season
no i mean i think there's obviously
there's always a resolution with the
housewives
to me it's never based in fact unless
you have proof i don't
there's no pictures there's no receipts
there's
nothing like that there is a resolution
but it's not based in fact
okay well you know your uh your friend
danielle staub is doing live streams
every week yes
yes yes people have sent it to me but
i'm blocked from her
i'm happy to be back we're gonna do this
all season
i hope you guys are pumped she put a
theory out there that you are actually
the source of the rumor
that's so bad oh my god margaret you
know this came from her that's why
margaret's pacing in the background
that's what's going on right now guys
okay now i figured it out
morgan's always underneath it behind it
that's why they filmed at her house
because she's the source
yes yeah i'm the source of the rumor
that's the funny part
yeah how funny is that she's like this
woman could really
i mean she'll throw anything at the wall
and make it stick
she's insane yeah that i i think my face
was obvious
i was the source of the room when teresa
said it i mean i was in shock
what do you make of her going live every
week and kind of i think
i think it's sad and desperate to hang
on
to something that was never hers
okay uh when you look at this big
picture
are you one side or the other are you
team teresa team jackie or you just
teammate fix this on team fix this
and team i stand on what's right i don't
think it was right at theresa i think
she was absolutely wrong
um that doesn't mean she's not my friend
obviously these are my friends and when
any of my friends do something wrong i
want them to apologize and make it right
i don't turn my
back on good people but she really went
below the belt
why do you think teresa was so unwilling
to let this go
because she's holding on to this thing
it feels you guys are trying to
rationalize with her say we'll get
jackie to apologize then you need to
apologize she seems unwilling
um i think it's because the analogy that
happened
i think then she felt vindicated i think
some for some reason that was she was
like oh well look what she said about
my daughter and for some reason i think
that that made her feel vindicated just
for whatever reason then she didn't have
to apologize
right away well we know this is just the
first of many dramas that are going to
come up this season
i went back into that trailer there
seems to be one
dinner at the shore that goes off
the rails we see you tell your husband
you've started a
storm oh yourself yes and
this isn't it what can you tell me about
that
you know the men are worse than the
women as far as i'm concerned with their
gossip
they have loose lips they drink and my
husband
is not always eloquent and says the
right things when he's drinking and
he says some things that he doesn't mean
it doesn't come across
right and it's misinterpreted and and i
tell him all the time
do not to speak out of term when you're
drunk you don't always say the right
things you have a problem
and he says some things that are um
misconstrued and it's inaccurate and i
know what he means when he speaks but
not everybody else's and
and he caused a very big problem and
hurt some people along the way and
i will hold anybody's feet to the fire
even my own family members and
my beloved joe and i held his feet to
the fire and it was not pretty
can you tell me who he caused drama with
you don't tell me what the drama is but
who's
that no i mean price that's why you
gotta wait to see but it's
it's upsetting it it was upsetting
enough that it it
i don't like to hurt anybody and and
innocent parties when they get hurt
i i feel horrible and i and i don't want
to be a part of something like that
jackie told me at the shore she got into
a screaming match with someone
unexpected as well
yes yes yeah okay so then you'll see
yeah but i mean that's all you know poor
jackie has it
jackie is a rough season i don't want to
ever see her hurt
for for no reason is that related at all
to joe and melissa going after theresa
and throwing the cheese plate are those
two sets no
no do you believe that's totally
separate that is totally separate
didn't understand that it almost feels
like this season everyone was locked up
for so long that as soon as you guys got
out of the house and had cameras on you
things just hit the fan it was like no
holding back
it is such authentic emotional
drama i think no one even knew what to
do i think
production was like in shock that's all
i could just say
they were like who are these people do
we even know them i know
in this next episode we're gonna see
some joe and melissa drama but in me
in my looking at the clips it feels like
maybe you guys are messing with joe
hello
i just want to let you know the owner of
the restaurant
asked melissa for her number they've
been texting
all day maybe you're calling him up and
saying melissa's flirting with the owner
of the restaurant just to get a rise out
of him
am i on to something i you could be on
to something but joe gorgo always
deserves a little
you know we like to stick it to him
sometimes and then there's this other
drama that
jennifer brings to the table of michelle
this new kind of friend of the show
saying that joe gorga owes her husband
money
yes so my husband and joe were working
on this event
and jordan pay my husband how much
technically do you think he owes your
husband
tens of thousands where does that go
well it's inaccurate and again not
not true at all anybody who
who comes with something you know from
18 months ago
is obviously not true
i think it's crazy my husband joe vorga
and frank work together every single
week
and there's never been one issue with
them
money flows freely between them and so i
just think this comes out of left field
okay like maybe somebody came in again
wanting to start some stuff
yes i just feel like it wasn't very
authentic or believable
it's obviously a twisty tourney season
what's going to surprise
the viewers the most about what's still
to come in season 11
the unexpected heightened emotions of
every couple and there's a lot of um
deep personal family things
amongst everybody that's really
you know that i think people just don't
know i think i think people can be
surprised about melissa and joe i think
she gets a hard time
saying oh that's not true this is it's
very very real
and and it was painful and i think
that's that's upsetting and also
never and no one ever sees me fight with
my husband and there's stories that i
reveal about my life that people don't
know and so everybody has some
deep emotion did in writing your book
did that
then bring things up that you had to
address with joe or your mom or
like does that cause some friction it
caused some things that
they didn't know about that my mom
doesn't know didn't know about that
that's emotional yes
not friction as much as pain emotional
pain
is there anything that you're kind of
bracing for impact for that you know is
gonna
make it to tv that you're not quite
ready to be out there
no okay no i think i think you know i'm
pretty much an open book and everyone's
going to read it so i think it's okay
on the flip side is there anything that
you're super excited for the viewers
to experience or to re-experience
yourself i think
i'm super excited that everyone's going
to finally see i have a kitchen you know
finally
i don't have to walk down the street
people say ciao when are you going to
fix the house
you know so i mean people really see us
in the street and that's what they
scream it's actually very funny
so i just feel like i've been gone well
not even people on the street i'll see
your co-stars on social media
oh yes yes my co-stars on social media
no one salt my taste
but you know i can't even someone who's
never been in the
the world that i that i've come from and
formally trained
it's irrelevant all right last question
what's your go-to iced coffee order this
season we've learned you love an iced
coffee
you want ice cropping i have it i have a
culvert oh my iced
coffee if i'm at a starbucks i go in
it's iced
uh coffee pumps and mocha with coconut
milk
that's at a starbucks my house is i do
my iced coffee out of the refrigerator
that's stock or you say stoke whatever
it is
unsweetened and i do funfetti creamer in
a red wine glass
with a straw because i put all my drinks
in a glamorous
glass but by the i never thought people
would be so obsessed with that i never
drank ice cream
in my life i know it's called pour it
from a glass